okay you pick the greenhouse that's a
good choice that's actually the one that
I've been wanting to go to this whole
time so thank you for picking it I'm so
excited I'm hoping there's some good
treats and now more tricks oh hey hey
there I wasn't really expecting any
trick-or-treaters uh let's see what I
have okay just one second um heard some
loose change okay you never know when
you're gonna need a penny and a dime you
never know there you go I see if I have
something else for you here's a fun size
deodorant okay only slightly used only
slightly used there you go there you go
one more thing okay one more thing let
me see there's some bacon everybody
wants bacon right okay but you know I
want to do the whole thing so just get
like two slices okay here you go if you
go happy halloween have fun of fun enjoy
the bacon don't spend all that loose
change in one place okay all right well
let's go to the house so click here to
go back to map guys click just you click